[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs rodina van
damme génère un salam aleikum salamon à
l'écho qui veut dire la paix soit sur
vous moi je me pose la question où nous
sommes sur le chemin de paix dans ce
monde
moi personnellement je viens d'un pays
où il n'y a surtout pas de paix je vous
parle de la syrie je suis né à damas la
ville de saint paul l'apôtre et de
saladin mais aussi c'est le siège dans
le régime
terrible la série a perdu la paix après
des longues années de ultra sécurité ou
le mot liberté est devenue un tabou
alors à l'âge de 19 ans
c'était dès les élections
présidentielles ou plutôt des
réélections mois avec une conscience
politique basique je voulais faire un
petit geste symbolique un acte héroïque
vis-à-vis de la menace policière je
voulais voter blanc alors j'arrive je
reçois mon bulletin de vote où il faut
il fallait choisir entre oui ou non
et alors grosse déception
la case de wii était cochée à l'avance
ce moment a marqué ma vie à jamais et
aggravé au moins le désir de liberté
donc voilà liberté d'expression 0
corruption et absence de perspectives
pour la jeunesse
il faut savoir que en syrie quand
partout dans le monde arabe la jeunesse
constitue donc 70 % de la population à
moins que 30 ans voilà les brises pardon
le bois était déjà sec
il manquait l'étincelle et ce sont les
brise de printemps arabe en 2011 qui
vont faire tousser le volcan trop
longtemps boucher la jeunesse pacifique
descendent dans les rues criant liberté
et dignité
ils reçoivent en retour le bruit des
fusils et puis des canons le sang coule
les hommes pères de la sagesse et la
bière commence et bien moi dans tout ça
les études furent ma boussole
j'ai réussi à avoir une inscription à
l'université catholique de louvain le
jour où j'arrive en belgique si vous
voulez je note sur mon facebook passage
deux pays
des pois chiches au pays des chicons
voilà ma nouvelle vie m'ouvre à la
liberté je peux penser librement
je peux dire ce que je pense au public
je peux même faire ce que je veux je
peux explorer les différents pensée
politique
le monde associatif l'aï 110 quand je
découvre tout à la fois la simplicité
volontaire
les pensées écologique
le barca me studio en temps et le
concept de l'année sabbatique à ce
moment là je pouvais me mesurer à quel
point le totalitarisme a arrosé à
travers l'histoire les rapports sociaux
dans la société arabe et vice versa dans
ma société d'origine à tout moment la
pression collectiviste exige la
conformité et toute la créativité et des
habits votre vie privée
jusque dans les moindres détails là
dessus les rapports de force sur
l'échelle sociale et la corruption
s'arrange pour vous faire croire que
bonheur égal biens matériels
c'est pourquoi j'ai vécu mon
déracinement comme un certain succès me
voilà je mange bio je trie mes déchets
je m'engage dans l'associatif et en même
temps je garde d'ailleurs je quote je
soupe
pourtant après trois ans de belgitude
je vivrai encore des chocs culturels la
différence existe bel et bien et il ne
se passera pas elle est en fait
nécessaire et naturel et cette anecdote
illustre est mon point de vue donc on
était ont soupé avec des ami es
quelqu'un emmené en plat de pâtes et de
deux ports alors moi je voulais faire
une petite expérience en tant pour logic
disons je voulais faire semblant que je
peux en manger et à ce moment là c'est
mon ami simon qui me dit non à m toi tu
es musulman tu peux pas en manger c'est
pas moi qui ai maintenu la différence
voilà
et donc si on j'essaye de résumer la
source des ces chocs culturels et se
remplit en philosophique je peux vous
dire que en occident en occident la
productivité et l'efficacité sont les
seules règles du jeu objectifs et
résultats
c'est la seule mesure ce sont les seules
mesures et tout ça ça mène à quoi a
decir ménages à de burnout inconnu chez
nous en occident
ici le mental le rationnel sans filtre
jusqu'à les la fois jusqu'à les
relations amoureuses
par contre chez nous son absence nous
embourber dans le fatalisme
ici la science se prend trop souvent
pour dieu
le concept de inch'allah par contre
laisse la place à l'imperfection humaine
et melesse réconcilier avec moi-même
avec l'existence et me garde jovial et
bon vivant
je travaille depuis certain temps longs
l'interculturel et l'inter
confessionnelles et cela me permette de
dire que le chemin de la paix me semble
être celui qui réconcilie les deux
mondes l'orient et l'occident
lerebours le monde arabe ont chacun un
chemin en chemin à faire en moins
d'abord et on vous si vous voulez bien
donc c'est à lorient de sortir de sa
position victimaire auto fabrique est
paralysante et qui se nourrit
systématiquement de la théorie du
complot tout notre malheur se serait-il
de la faute des autres
arrêtons de nous déresponsabiliser les
choses pourrait-elle s'arranger par un
seul cours de destin arrêtons de nous
auto stigmatiser les arabes
serait-il pas fait pour la démocratie
puis c'est aux migrants de s'ouvrir un
autre rapport à vrai que leur pays
d'accueil
une seconde patrie c'est autre chose
qu'un simple rapport matériel travail et
business
ensuite si je peux me permettre c'est à
l'occident de comprendre que pour
connaître l'autre il ne suffit pas de se
confier à la politique de éplucher les
feuilles journal les lunettes politique
ne suffisent pas pour comprendre
l'histoire humaine notamment de lorient
celle ci ne se résume pas au complot ni
au complot ni à l'islamisme alors
pratiquement cinq choses aux en plus de
rencontres vrai concrètes empathique et
fidèle dans le temps 2 osons d'explorer
l'humain de côtoyer nos différences et
habiter nouvelles habilités pour un
monde moins violent
donnons de l'espace à l'art la poésie la
musique ce sont des lieux où la
différence
les différences de vienne apaisement et
beauté et puis n'oublions pas de nous
engager les uns et les autres les uns
pour les autres
pour un monde plus juste soyons acteurs
responsables puis lâche on aux ambitions
matériel trop matériel je crois en la
pertinence de la simplicité volontaire
et écologique
je voudrais que le tueur et en disons
merci d'abord à ma famille d'accueil
avec qui le partage de notre différence
en profondeur à m'a permis d'élargir ma
foi même merci à la belgique qui mord
qui a élargi ma vision du monde m'a
permis de côtoyer l'afrique comme le
maroc la turquie l'italie c'est la
belgique qui au delà de la belgitude à
déranger mes certitudes et booster et
inspiré ma vie engagée dans qu elle
merci beaucoup c'est alarmant à l'écran
[Applaudissements]